hey everyone diavelo here and in today's
video we're going to be going over the
entire black dragons arc from tokyo
avengers which is most likely what the
season 2 of the anime is going to be
covering bar a little bit of the tng arc
if it does manage to get all the way
there if you guys are new around here
want to keep up to date with latest
tokyo avengers content and just more
other anime content in general then make
sure you hit that subscribe button and
also be sure to leave a like on the
video as it really helps out with the
algorithm and pushes my stuff to a bunch
of new amazing people also if you do
want to check out the entire tokyo
avengers story so far then make sure you
go and check out my video that i'll
leave a link to down in the description
below this is just separately one of the
arcs from the entire story that i've
decided to put in its own separate video
as this is what i think the season 2 of
the anime will be covering but anyway
enough of that let's get into this black
dragon's arc
after he arrives back in the past
takamichi is with hakai as they approach
the sheba household yuzuha remarks that
they might be in trouble as their
brother is coming back home all of a
sudden in front of them numerous members
of the black dragons gang stand yuzaha
urges takamichi to leave with hina and
as they are about to leave taiju
suddenly appears behind them lunging at
takamichi knocking him to the ground
taiju continues to beat up takamichi
then asks who he is he learns of
takamichi status as tomen's first
division captain and laughs in disbelief
that hakai brought a member of toman to
their home while hakai begs for his
brother to show mercy towards takamichi
takamichi notes that hekai's mentality
has changed in the presence of his
brother taiju tells hikai that their
relationship as brothers takes priority
over the relationships within tomon
causing yuzah to confront taiju telling
him not to corner hakai in response
taiju punches her blaming her lack of
discipline towards hakai and warning her
that he will deal with her later to get
his brother to stop hakai is forced to
say that he will quit tomon and join the
black dragons
when takamichi awakes from
unconsciousness he has been carried on
hikai's back with hina at his side
takamichi apologizes for forcing hakai
to leave tomen but hakai says that he
had already decided to leave a while ago
takamishi suddenly remembers what the
future katatura told him about hakai and
how he would kill his older brother for
money then take over the black dragons
lion and beard takamichi begins to piece
together what will happen hakai will
kill taiju and merge the black dragons
with tomen resulting in the bad future
he saw
however he does not think that he has to
stop hakai from killing taiju as he
concludes that the black dragons will be
a threat regardless of the leader
takamichi suspects that shifuyu will
tell him not not to deal with the
conflict alone but shifuyu simply tells
him to have fun as baji did not leave
tarman to him in order to bring stress
into takamichi's life abruptly takamichi
confesses that he came from the future
shifuyu asks takamichi what he means by
saying he is from the future overwhelmed
by his burden takamichi tells shifuyu
everything that has happened to him thus
far including how shifuyu sacrificed
himself for takamichi shifuyu believes
takamichi telling him that somehow he
always knew the truth like sometimes
takamichi looks different and somehow he
knew that bhaji was going to die during
the bloody halloween incident
although takamichi feels powerless in
his failures shifuyu tells him that he
is incredible later shifu says the
thought of getting killed by kisaki
along with the premeditation of bhaji's
death angers him enough to kill kisaki
however takamichi and shifuyu know they
are weak compared to kisaki's third
division which has over a hundred men as
well as the new sixth division which is
made up of valhalla members and hanma
two days later the leaders of tomen have
a meeting at the tomen meeting draken
says that taiju's attack on takamichi
acts as a declaration of war by the
black dragons hakai tells the group that
he expects punishment for his brother's
actions and requests to leave tomorrow
as takamichi frantically thinks about
what to do draken asks mikey what his
decision is mikey replies that he will
allow matsuya to decide since hakai
belongs in mitsuya's division as
takamichi witnesses what he sees as
another failure to change the future
matsuya tells akai that he did not
permit him to leave and asks to talk to
taiju hakai tries to dissuade mitsuya
from meeting with taiju to which matsuya
reassures him telling hikai that he
always tries to handle these issues
alone
at tarju's place he accused mitsuya of
negatively influencing hakai and
threatens to kill him matsuya tells
taiju that he will not see hakai again
allowing him to join the black dragons
on one condition tajiu must stop his
domestic violence against yuzah and
mitsuya believes that hikai is joining
the black dragons to protect yusaha in
response taji punches mitsuya who
brushes off the assault he repeats his
conditions to taiju and taiju ends up
agreeing telling matsuya that he will
not hit yuzuha again takamichi and
shifuyu reflect on what just happened as
their goal of preventing hakai from
leaving tomond failed however takamichi
now believes that hakai will kill taiju
to protect yusuha hakai approaches them
and asks to thanks matsuya for him when
takamichi asks why hakai says that his
home life is complicated and says that
he and his siblings grew up without the
presence of either parent which put
taiju in charge akai says that he has
sworn to protect his family ever since
mitsuya told him that violence should be
used to protect others from then on
hakai has been taking beatings for
yuzuha in addition to his own however
taiju beat yuzah regardless
hakai explains the agreement taiji made
with mitsuya will likely have no value
to him and he will continue to hurt
yuzuha when takamichi asks what they can
do to help hakai confesses that he is
terrified and powerless when facing his
brother he says that things would be
better if taiji was not around and that
he does not want to give tomen a bad
name so he left the gang to pursue his
intentions to kill taiju as he leaves
them hakai says that the short time they
spent together was fun takamichi tells
shifuyu that hikai's situation angers
him as it gives him little choice but to
kill his brother takamichi and shifuyu
pledge to defeat the black dragons and
create a better future as a cafe
takamichi and shifuyu tell the other
captains of their desire to fight the
black dragons draken smiley and mucho
firmly reject this as it would break
matsuya's agreement and ruin his
reputation take me she decides that he
and shifuyu will deal with the issue on
their own
suddenly hisaki offers to help takamachi
and shifu and their goal to stop hakai's
plan to kill taiju kisaki says that they
do not have another choice as they would
easily be overpowered by the black
dragons without the support of the other
divisions kisaki says that he wants to
stop the black dragons from gaining more
power angered by kisaki's disrespect
towards mikey shifuyu holds a shard of
broken glass to kisaki's neck telling
him not to act superior in response
hanuma holds a knife to takamichi's neck
reminding shifuyu that infringing is
prohibited to convince shifuyu kisaki
reveals that there is a mole within the
black dragons they pay a hundred
thousand yen to the mall who is feared
of getting caught kasaki reassures him
that no one will turn on him just as he
is beginning to tell them koko bursts
into the room declaring that he smells a
rat spotting the one hundred thousand on
the table koko says that he will tell
them what they want to know if he is
given that money hisaki requests to know
when taiji is alone koko says that taiji
was never alone as he is always guarded
with five soldiers save for a single day
christmas day when takamichi asks why
koko is betraying taiju he says that he
just likes strong guys kisaki tells
takamichi that he did not want to know
when taji was alone to kill him instead
he suspects that this is when hakai will
try to kill taiju hisaki tells takamichi
that he wants to know by tomorrow
whether or not they will work together
shifuyu is opposed to working with
kisaki due to his hatred but takamichi
hopes to use the opportunity to find
information on kisaki he and takamichi
find them to let them know but make sure
to emphasize that their collaboration is
only to further their goals as they
dislike each other as takamichi walks
home a man approaches him introducing
himself as heine and nayoto's father
masato tachibana sitting down at the
restaurant masato tells takamichi that
his wife has told him a lot about him
such as him dating hina takamichi is
visibly nervous in front of heine's
father but masato reassures him telling
takamechi that he does not need to be
nervous up until recently naoto hated
his father's job as it kept them apart
but now he wants to become a police
officer masato attributes this change to
takamichi and thanks him sincerely
bowing he then asks takamichi to do a
favour for him takamichi sits alone in
the restaurant processing the favour
masato asked him the favor that masato
asked was that he wants takamichi to
break up with hina due to the status of
takamichi being a delinquent on
christmas eve takamichi is late as he
told shifu that he has something small
to take care of quickly he meets up at
umashita park with hina and tells her
that they should break up saying that he
found another girl and does not love her
anymore in response hina punches him
telling takamichi that he is a jerk as
taking me she lies in the snow he
convinces himself that he's made the
right decision since it could keep hina
from kisaki's violence takamichi arrives
at the cafe where kisaki hanma and
shifuyu are waiting hama ridicules
takamichi's swollen eyes and kisaki lays
out the plan for the next day he
speculates that hakai will attack taichu
in the church so they will wait for
taiji outside the chapel takamichi is
given the role of reasoning with akai
while the rest of the group will beat
down taiju outside although he does not
know what takamichi did before the
meeting shifuhu tells him to use his
anger to motivate himself tomorrow on
christmas day hakai puts on his black
dragons uniform and promises to settle
everything meanwhile tajiu leaves the
black dragons in the temporary command
of koku and inupay as he prepares to
observe his annual christmas ritual of
going to church alone
shifuyu approaches takamichi and bows
telling takamichi how baji impacted his
life he then presents baji's ceremonial
sash to takamichi who promises to honour
bhaji's legacy by facing obstacles head
on just like how baji did with all four
of them wearing their uniforms complete
with their sashes they approach the
church takamichi reminds himself that
they have to fight this battle alone
without depending on tomen right before
he enters the church shifuyu reassures
takamichi telling him that persuading
hikai is the most important aspect of
the plan entering the church takamichi
finds sakai standing in front of the
altar
he calls him out and hakai turns around
asking takamichi why he is here
takamichi replies that he is here to
stop hakai's plan to kill taiju just
then taiju enters the church reciting a
prayer upon seeing him takamichi wonders
what happened to kasaki and the others
who were supposed to defeat taiju
irritated tides you demand to know why
they are in the church when just as
tajin says there hikaya lunges adam with
the knife screaming in one of the
church's rooms hanuman restrained
shifuyu remarking that he put up a good
fight wakisaki watches meanwhile taju
easily stops akai's attack and begins
strangling him telling hakai that he
only acts tough and admonishing him for
failing to kill him telling him not to
yell instead hakai should have quietly
stabbed him from behind taiju taunts
akai telling him that his back is open
to stab only using half of his power
taji punches takamichi causing him to
lose consciousness as takamiji struggles
to come back too he is terrified by
taiju's power believing that he may even
be killed meanwhile taju continues to
haunt hakai who cannot do anything out
of fear he tells hakai that he plans to
kill takamichi as he strangles takamichi
taiju asks if he knows why hakai wants
to kill him takamichi responds that it
is because of taiji's abuse towards
yusuha which causes taiju to laugh and
taunt hakkai he threatens to reveal
hakai's secret telling takamichi that
hikai is not the sort of person he
thinks he is
before taiju can continue yuzuha appears
behind him with a knife shocked
takamishi calls her out just before she
stabs taichu in the back in response
taiji releases takamichi and punches
yuzaha throwing her across the church
hakai angrily accuses takamichi of
telling yuzah his plans as only
takamichi knows however yuzah reveals
that kosaki told her everything
intentionally takamichi wonders if
kisaki goaded yusuha into killing taiju
and the future rumors about hakai
killing his brother were false
reflecting on this takamichi realizes
that yuzuha killed taiju in the original
timeline just then taiju takes off his
coat revealing that the stab wound is
shallow a tribute team tokuminshi's
shout to helping him to avoid a severe
wound seeing this takamishi realizes
that he saved taiju wondering if he
avoided the future in which kisaki
manipulates hikai taiju abuses sakai and
yuzah for trying to kill him their
brother he tells them that he has done a
lot for their sake which you use a hard
dispute telling taiju that he did it all
for himself taiju punches yuzuha once
again throwing her against the altar
allowed taju questions why god puts him
through ordeals such as being forced to
murder his own sister taju tells yuzah
that he will kill her when she charges
at him taju punches her and says that he
will slowly beat her to death putting
himself between them takamichi tells
tajiu to calm down and says that he is
the one tearing his family apart while
believing that he cares about them
takamichi tells akai to protect his
sister and asks what he is so scared of
just then taju punches takamichi and
throws another pew at him saying that
his siblings were the ones trying to
hurt him in the first place takamichi
narrowly avoids the pew as well and
exclaims that trying to kill each other
does not make sense standing up yuzaha
tells him that it is the path all of
them chose thinking back to how hakai
has been protecting yuzuha takamichi
determines that yuzuha is the key to the
events she killed taiju in the original
timeline after being instigated by
kisaki the hakai took responsibility as
the killer using this knowledge he said
he was able to manipulate hikai who
assumed leadership of the black dragons
leading to the corruption of tomen
takamichi declares he has to beat down
taiju believing that protecting yuzah
will stop the corruption of tomen hakai
tells him that he does not know the full
extent of taji's violence grabbing her
knife yuzah tells takamichi not to get
in her way as she will protect hakai
suddenly mitsuya appears grabbing
yuzah's blade as he tells her to let go
of the knife saju asks what happened to
their agreement and taunts matsuya for
breaking it matsuya says that he will
tell tajiu something more important even
if she misbehaves he should never hurt
his little sister instead she should be
forgiven with a smile which is what
being an older brother is about
outside on his cb250t
mikey asks stricken if he heard
mitsuya's bike shivering draken tells
mikey that he is hearing things as no
one would be stupid enough to ride a
bike in the cold weather meanwhile
matsuya and taiju fight watakamichi
noting that matsuya can match taiju's
strength suddenly matsuya takes her knee
and taju taunts him to the relief of
hakai takamichi and shifuyu matsuya was
just tightening a strap on his boot as
they continue to fight akai tells
matsuya to stop a pointless battle as he
believes that he cannot win against
taiju's strength anupai appears behind
mitsuya and swings a pipe at his head
which causes him to collapse
azakai screams for mitsuya koko enters
and asks the group if his information
was worth one hundred thousand much to
hikai's horror matsuya is motionless on
the ground shifuyu and takamichi prepare
to fight taichu koko and anupay just as
takamichi and shifuyu charge it taiju
matsuya gets up and tells them to calm
down as he is alright however he still
sways from the impact of the pipe
sitting down matsuya acknowledges the
direness of the situation taiju koko and
inyupay are all strong while he and
shifu are already all beat up leaving
takamachi as the only one able to fight
however matsuya says that if they lose
yuzah may even get killed takamichi
tells mitsuya not to worry as mikey and
the others will come to help so all they
have to do is stall for time until they
arrive matsuya asks takamichi if he
called mikey which confuses him as
takamichi had thought that matsuya would
have called mikey matsuya responds that
he came here alone to help hakai as an
issue unrelated to tomen he says that
the three of them alone will have to
protect yuzah
overwhelmed takamichi falls to his knees
he believes that there is no possible
way that they can win against the black
dragons and that they will all be killed
matsuya tells hakai that he is under no
obligation to help since he is a black
dragon member however he asks hakai to
help him to protect yuzah as hakai
stammers matsuya says he understands how
fearful he is of taiju takamichi screams
to motivate himself and he and shifuyu
prepare to fight shifuyu will take on
inyupay and takamichi will take on koko
because koko is willing to sell
information about taiju he might be
willing to stop the fight if taiji was
significantly weakened with shifuyu
already worn out from his fight with
hanuma and takamichi's limited fighting
skills they struggle to hold back and
you pay and koko tsakaminchi says that
he cannot hold off koko for much longer
and koko notes that they are stalling
for time until mitsuya and hakai can
defeat taiju as matsuya rushes towards
taji begins laughing turning around
matsuya sees that hikai has not moved
trembling hakai apologizes to matsuya
for his lack of resolve tarju asks what
matsuya was expecting from a person like
hakai then punches him just then
takamichi is kneed by koko and shifuyu
collapses on the floor grabbing his
knife and rushing towards taiju hakai
tries to gain the resolve to kill taiju
still coughing and panting from the
impact of koko's attack takamichi puts
himself between hakai and taiju grasping
hikai's blade takamichi tells him that
he will become an irredeemable person if
he follows through with the act as
murdering someone is no way to fight
back telling hikaya that he will show
what it means to fight back takamichi
prepares to face taiju who remarks that
takamichi has not learned his past
lesson even after being attacked by
taiju numerous times tatu easily
counters takamishi's attacks with a
punch to his face by the time taju asks
how many times he has to punch takamichi
until he gives up takamichi's face is
swollen and bloodied but he refuses to
lose seeing takamichi's wounded face
shifuyu weeps telling him to stop and
accept defeat takamichi grasps the
necklace that hina gave him asking for
courage he concludes that as long as
taiju and the black dragons exist hakai
will be unable to stand up for himself
takamichi tells taiju that he will
defeat him and take control of the black
dragons in response tatu punches him
once more but takameki declares that he
is not done yet shifuyu implores
takamichi to stop fighting taiju telling
him that he will die if he continues
takamishi believes that the future may
not necessarily change if he continues
fighting but if there's a small chance
of that happening he will continue to
risk his life just then he and tiju
simultaneously punch each other in the
face and takamichi is thrown back by the
force while tatu remarks that
takamichi's punch did not even hurt
however to taiju's shock he falls onto
his knees as takamichi unsteadily gets
back up hakai begs him to stop with a
beason and bloody face he tells akai
that fighting on is not painful what
hurts him more than anything is
loneliness as in you pay coco yuzah
mitsuya and shifuyu react in shock when
takamichi compels taiju to his knees
takamichi tells zakai that he will
protect yuzah for him hakai tells
takamichi that he is wrong as his own
face does not have a bruise while yusuha
is injured although his encounter with
mitsuya made him want to protect his
family he did not have the courage to
stand up to taiju he confesses that he
lied to takamichi about his
circumstances instead of him protecting
yusaha from taiju it was yuzaha who
tried to protect him from taking twice
the amount of beatings hakai apologizes
to takamichi for involving him in this
situation through his fear in response
takamichi tells zakai that he sucks for
his actions but he says that he sucks
more himself referring to his past
cowardice and their lack of resolve
standing up matsuya also tells akai that
he sucks but says that he was
hypocritical for telling hikai not to
hate the situation he was born into when
he hated his own takamishi says that his
true family will not abandon him because
of a lie as this is what thomann should
be about as shifuyu mitsu and takamichi
watchikai tell taiju that he will beat
him down to protect his family shifuyu
observes that hikai has changed instead
of deciding to kill taiju hakai has
decided to beat him down shifuyu tells
takamichi that the future will change
meanwhile tajiu asks aloud why god
continues to test him by compelling him
to kill both of his siblings with a
swift punch taju knocks hakai
unconscious tajiu tells shifuyu matsuya
and takamichi that they will have to die
as well as there are a hundred black
dragon members outside blocking them
from escape looking out their window
shifuyu confirms this takamishi tells
shifu that they do not intend to run
away as the future will not change until
they defeat taji and the black dragons
as yuzuha watches the others fighting
the black dragons for the sake of akai
she realizes that she is not alone
shifuyu having fought inupay falls to
the ground with an injured leg while
mitsuya fighting koko takes a knee from
his exhaustion takamichi staggers from
his injuries and taiju tells hikai that
he is an idiot as he will end up losing
everything hakai tells him to shut up
and learn his lesson in hell just then
hakai remarks that he is starting to
hear things however it is not just a
hallucination but the sound of mikey's
cb250t
approaching from the distance as taiju
koko and inyupay wonder why mikey is
here takamiki exclaims with relief that
they can now defeat the black dragons
with mikey's aid maki enters the church
and wishes everyone a merry christmas
smiling he asks what they are all doing
mikey says that his older brother
recognized the impulse sound of
matsuya's bike and bhaji said that only
matsuya's bike sounded that nice and the
two of them led mikey to the church
takamichi and mitsuya are concerned as
both shinichiro and bhaji are dead when
taju approaches maiki mahi asks why he's
standing in his way as he just wants to
ride with his friends
taiju punches mikey in the face and
knocks him unconscious
as the church bells chime taiji declares
his victory against the so-called
invincible mikey
angered by this matsuya lunges at taiju
but just then maki rises behind a shock
taiju telling him that prayer time is
now over taiju tells mahi that his punch
was the best that he had thrown all day
additionally matsuya and takamichi are
unnerved by mikey's strange behavior as
he referenced shinichiro and bhaji as if
they were still alive as takamichi
wonders if mahi will be defeated mikey
responds that the punch he took from
taju was just punishing himself before
he can comprehend what happened taiji
was lying unconscious at mikey's feet
to the shock and awe of everyone there
mikey flies through the air and knocks
taiju unconscious maki says that he
decided to go out riding with bhaji and
sharachiro every christmas
and takamishi is concerned about mikey's
mental state until mikey takes out
bhaji's omamori charm explaining that
when he rides with his brother's bike
and baji's charm it's like they are
still there with him hearing this
takamishi is sure that mikey will not
turn evil mikey prepares to leave the
church telling them to go on a ride but
taiju held up by any pay tries to
prevent them from leaving he orders koko
to bring in the black dragons members
from outside saying that he refuses to
lose to anyone
crawling to the entrance of the church
taiju finds dracon waiting outside on
his steps with all the black dragons
members defeated on the ground even
though they are already worn out from
their previous fights takamichi shifuyu
prepares to fight the 100 black dragons
members outside of the church
just then draken enters the church and
asks why everyone is so tense as he
informs mikey that he has defeated all
of the black dragons waiting outside
with taiju's will to fight gone and the
black dragons defeated tomen has
effectively ended the black dragons
rushing out of the church yuzuha shifuyu
and matsuya marvel at draken's strength
takamichi cries in relief when he notes
that everyone has survived telling
shifuyu that his mission is complete as
he faints from exhaustion everyone
agrees that the role takaminchi played
in the knights events was of the utmost
importance before leaving hakai and
yuzaha speak to their brother
hakai asks a silent taijo how his first
ever loss failed he tells taiju that he
is strong and will recover shortly but
he and yuzah will never give in to
taiju's abuse again after this takamichi
asks what they are doing at heine's home
and mikey doesn't provide a helpful
response as heena stands before him
takamichi feels awkward and does not
know what to say as the way he dumped
her was completely one-sided seeing
tokumichi's swollen and bloody face hina
simply asks if he got into another fight
takamichi begins to tear up and bursts
into tears apologizing to hina although
he understands where her father is
coming from he tells her that he cannot
let her get her after he swore to save
her which confuses hina even if she gets
run over by a truck and becomes
paralyzed he says he will save her no
matter how many tries it takes takamichi
tearfully asks if they can get back
together hina tells takamichi to take
her to the shrine on new years and tells
them that they have made up takamichi
touched by the moment begins to cry
after they leave heena's maiki tells
takamichi that sometimes he does not
know what is going on his brother should
be alive but he is not and he does not
understand what this means during this
time mikey says that he becomes
disorientated and unable to tell the
difference between right and wrong
takamichi realizes that mikey is
self-aware of the darkness inside him
and the potential of that darkness to
take hold of him maki tells takameshi
that his brother sparkled brighter than
anything when he led his gang the
members were sure they would not lose as
they could rely on shinichiro takamichi
says that mikey is just like his brother
but mikey says that he is just weak
while takamichi is strong maki asks
takamichi to scold him like his brother
would if he loses control of himself
takamichi promises that he will
meanwhile as they look over the city
harma remarks that he never expected
takamichi to pull off what happened on
christmas night however kisaki says it
will not end here
drakken announces the beginning of
toman's first meeting of the year he and
mikey informed tomin of the conflict
with taiju and the black dragons through
the testimony of three people called to
the front hakai takes responsibility for
the conflict as it all started with a
lie he told the second person called up
is inyupay who was with koko nui because
the 10th generation black dragons lost
to tomen and taji retired they are now
the leaders of the 11th generation after
talking with mikey they have decided to
join under tomen mikey assigns them to
the first division under takamichi's
command much to everyone's shock when
takamichi asks what the reasoning behind
the decision was mikey says that both
inupi and koko wanted to be under his
command the last person mikey calls up
is kisaki regarding his involvement in
the christmas conflict maki tells kisaki
that he is fired
a shock kisaki asks maki if he is joking
but mikey says he is not approaching the
stage hanuma says that if mikey is fired
then he will leave as well maki says
that he does not care as tomin has
gotten too big in response kisaki
reminds mikey that expanding tomen is
his goal to which mikey asks if kisaki's
instigation of the christmas conflict
was a way to expand tomin shifuyu
reiterates that he did not think kisaki
would be fired as he and mitsuya did not
have concrete evidence of kisaki's
betrayal a panicked kisaki runs towards
mikey telling him that he has grown weak
as taji posed a threat to tomen so he
acted for mikey's sake draken appears in
front of kisaki asking who allowed him
to come near mikey hanuma swings at
drakken telling him to let kisaki tour
watching this takamichi wonders if
kasaki is desperate as he can no longer
achieve his goal of becoming mikey's
right hand man mikey upholds his
decision telling hisaki that his
arbitrary actions will ruin his dream
later on they reveal a cb250 bike to
takamachi which maki remarks is the same
bike as his he says his brother found
two engines for the bike in the
philippines where they were lying
abandoned mikey says that someday he
wants to go to the place where his
brother found the engines and takamichi
agrees after his time leap takamichi
finds himself at a shrine meaning that
he was able to change the future as he
wonders if hina has been saved a woman
approaches him remarking that it's been
an extremely long time since they last
saw each other takamichi discerns that
he is at a funeral but does not know
whose from the conversation between two
of the deceased sisters a shocked
takamichi realises the funeral is for
mitsuya
entering the temple he is horrified to
find a picture of mitsuya surrounded by
flowers when he checks his phone he
finds that matsuya's death is suspected
to be a murder additionally hina was
killed dying in exactly the same way as
before
entering his apartment he finds it as
familiar as ever as he wonders how the
events transpired takamichi notices the
final photo he took with mikey and the
others just then naoto enters the
apartment telling takamichi that he has
been looking for him as his memory was
overwritten naoto says that this is the
worst future that has occurred thus far
shifuyu was shot to death hakai was
burned to death matsuya was strangled to
death and dracon was stabbed to death
additionally other chief members of
tomen were murdered as well including
kazatora parchin and even kisaki naoto
reveals that maki is the one who
perpetrated all of the murders a shocked
takamichi insists that mikey would never
kill anyone and naoto says that he wants
to know the truth as well naoto asks if
takamechi would know anything about this
as he could have gained information from
the past and also asks where takamichi
found the photo and takomichi responds
that he found it on top of the table
they find a letter from the philippines
on the table sent from mikey after
reading the letter and deducing where
maki is takamichi and naoto arrive in
manila and the philippines monkey's
leader asked them to meet at the place
he told takamichi about where his
brother found the two bike engines
eventually takamichi finds a pile of old
bike parts which was the location mikey
told him about
behind him mikey calls his name turning
around takamichi sees that mikey has the
same look in his eyes as he did 12 years
ago mikey says that tomen has changed he
asks takamichi why he left homan as he
wanted takamichi to stay with him
reminding takamichi of his request to be
scolded as his brother would have if he
stepped out of line mikey recalls him
trying to stop takamichi from leaving
tomen but both dracon and mitsuya
believe that takamichi should go
throwing a gun at takamichi's feet mikey
requests a tfo takamichi to kill him a
confused takamichi tells him to stop as
he only wanted to see mikey again mikey
tells takamichi that it was difficult to
achieve his goals but when he killed
someone for the first time he felt
nothing instead he found killing as an
easy solution to most of the world's
problems shaking him takamichi tells
mikey that he can tell that he has not
changed from 12 years ago
mikey tells him to stop and slams
takamichi onto the ground pressing a gun
to his cheek as he cries he tells
takamichi that they can not bring back
the past and a shot rings out now so
shoots mike in the head he then cautions
takamichi to stay away from mikey just
in case naosu then notices the safety on
mikey's gun was on
meaning that he never intended to kill
takamichi in the first place mikey
thanks naoto for shooting him as he says
that takamichi probably could not have
before he dies he remarks that
takamichi's hand is warm
crying takamichi remembers the many
moments they shared together from when
they first met to when mikey told him
that he was strong holding mikey's body
and his arms a determined lock flashes
across takamichi's face so i hope you
all enjoyed the black dragon's arc by
far it's probably one of my favorite
arcs if not my favorite arc it's
definitely up there in my like top two
or three it's fighting with tenjiku for
being that number one arc for me to be
honest as i just love the dynamic that
we have with takamichi kind of being
separated from the entire group and
having to work with his enemy somewhat
in this and not knowing whether or not
he's actually going to be working with
him and then finding out that he's
actually betrayed him and just wanted to
see takamichi squirm the entire time and
i just love how takamichi you know
everyone calls him weak and just a
punchy bag and all reality he is but
even at some point in that fight he
manages to drop taiju down into one knee
which is insanely impressive from
someone takamichi's size so i absolutely
love this arc and i hope you guys did as
well if you guys do want to catch up on
all of the tokyo avengers story so far
then be sure to go down to the comment
section below like i said at the start
of the video then click on that link and
you can catch up over on that video if
not then keep an eye out for the tenjiku
and bontine arcs which i will be
uploading probably over the next few
weeks anyway if you have enjoyed the
video and haven't already make sure you
hit that subscribe button and also be
sure to leave a like as well as it
really helps out with the algorithm and
pushes my stuff to a bunch of new
amazing people but anyway enough of that
for now it's been your professional
degenerate diavolo and i'll see you all
any bit bye
[Music]
you